little baby dropped a whole can of mid
I'm gonna let people know 10 hours in
wait so really yeah there's a whole can
of made really whole can of men you
can't name two songs from there that's
true that's fact
four out of four but I love me a
threesome
by the way here's the interesting part
too because what I was thinking about
responses
I prefer floor but I love me at three
got you got you but uh but I only know
if the album's good or not if Grand
wizard post about it he said the album
was fire you gotta pay for that one
really
no brand was you taking money [ __ ]
Gotta Get Paid bro I mean he deserves it
it's the best school grandparation it's
the best Instagram it's not bad it's
just it's a bunch of forgettable songs
okay and people wanted some more hits
there's not one bona fide hit on there
hmm Alex disagrees I think
um
yeah who are in similar maybe not at the
same position he's at but is in the
similar echelons they're all shocked
that this is the album that was dropped
granted he dropped 18 months of hits
yeah yeah right on
um on me all those songs hits hits hits
hits hits he drops his first two songs
going into his album one's called hey
you know I mean I thought it was an
lgbtq you know I mean Anthony hey hey
it's crazy
how did you do that thing that was yeah
that was impressive there you went hey
hey hey
and also but you keep on doing it and
that's what that's what he do oh really
yeah
so he dropped he dropped two mid songs
yeah he went into the album yeah and
then the album just really has a bunch
of men on it it's not trash though right
but he was in a position to elevate by
dropping a banger and the Banger isn't
there here's the thing I even though
it's not trash I could also amplify the
I'm going to amplify the fact that it's
mid which might be just a detrimental if
it was trash sorry I see what you're
saying how long has it been out though
uh it's been on tweets though
like that bro I'm telling you Drake
coming next week we got big Taylor Who's
in the building she's dropping some
amazing [ __ ] you know I mean nobody's
listening to like
particular songs of that does it still
get played of course he's popular
so as I said with me I play the slow
game with every rapper I said a nice
little three years you know I mean every
rapper I look at it I'm like
you're the man right now huh I say this
and it's more of a compliment than
anything but you do seem different than
you were last time I think it's mature
because last time you were like these
rappers ain't touching me ain't none of
them doing anything ain't nothing about
that life I mean it was nothing I feared
for your life no little baby
about that life but that's not where I'm
at with them and also even though I'm
I'm gonna dismiss that could get touch
comment because all y'all under
investigation so you're not gonna have
me over here like oh my God this this
big bag No the reason why ever since I
mentioned it I got called from everybody
from Atlanta is because they know it's
real these rappers in Atlanta can't
really rap about [ __ ] because the D.A is
on everybody's necks so I just say don't
if y'all ran out of people to be tough
against don't try to get the oh I could
be tough versus ad point because I'm not
even believing I don't feel in fear my
life overload do you think that impacted
the album though that he wasn't able to
rap about maybe like maybe his most
fired tracks
Hey listen
Gutter and Thug got locked up and they
had a bunch of songs slated to drop
either individually or with other people
or got can you know why you don't want
to be releasing potentially more
evidence that people are going to be
here
you can't put them out and let's keep it
real the most self-incriminating bars
usually hit the hardest hardest come on
man yes I shot [ __ ] over there you know
what I mean left the body over there I
got the gun on me now like
I can't say that no more like it's a
wrap so what should they have done does
not put it out well it's it's been a
couple years since this album was
released so he couldn't push it back any
further I think they just got to be
creative you know they're in a tough
spot and that's why I did explain the
whole like when people are saying oh
you're gonna stand up no like man we're
not into no issues and if he did get
into the legal problem it would never be
against me so don't I don't want if
something happens to him people look for
the scapegoating since I'm the popular
guy to blame it on me yeah yeah yeah but
I know they're all in a tough
predicament I'm just saying I don't
believe that rap how does hip-hop adjust
why what is it about Atlanta
you got a D.A that's trying to become
Kamala Harris uh you know she's realized
that rappers are kind of you know the
moment that T.I said that Atlanta was
the black
um or it was the modern day wakanda yeah
every rapper was going there having a
lot of success in the retreating the
community like this was some place that
rappers could operate more than just
celebrities so
some of what the this is what the police
are saying they believe a lot of them
rappers down there they start to get
into street gangs and start funding them
what does that do start funding crime oh
crime is going up so crime is going up
for like the last six seven years and
they're looking for a blame they're
looking for and every time when somebody
gets killed and they catch the
perpetrator perpetrator is going to be
like yo I'm representing this game and
they say what's the name of the gang I
won't say no names but they'll notice
this gang is being blasted through the
speakers all over the town
it's inevitable and if you're the D.A
and you take down a big public-facing
person even if it's not the main person
great for you it looks great for your
reps and also it took this D.A to do it
because it's a black D.A
and interesting
if it's a wife listen racism if it's
white it's a white person absolutely
there's a ba in Philly who named a bunch
of like you know gangs that also some of
them are like rap groups too yeah and
people look at them like the way you set
that kind of racist you know what I mean
yeah when it's a black woman it's like
don't say nothing
now now that's interesting because I
know that just speaking from like some
friends who live in Atlanta they're
tired of the crime like they're like
it's ridiculous yo yeah like like I even
you know [ __ ] I told Duvall to meet me
in Buckhead right yeah because I'm
feeling [ __ ] it's nice he goes he
goes no I can't go over there he'll go
why are they robbing over there I can't
do it like that was his excuse for not
wanting to go out to have dinner right
and he goes oh it's not the weird thing
is is this is we'll go in there someone
might recognize me in the restaurant
yeah yeah and then a phone call is made
and all of a sudden they're waiting for
me to go get my car outside or they're
following it down yeah so it's like
inside jobs everywhere yeah yeah so when
the community is that frustrated with
the crime they're looking for I don't
want to call it a scapegoat if they're
directly involved but if they're not
involved you're not going to brag about
crime in a place where people are fed up
with the [ __ ] crime yeah so I see why
there's so much popularity with the D.A
even amongst the people in Atlanta yeah
well that day is very personable to the
people that's not in the rap precincts
like for example the reason why Thug and
gun in jail is because before she became
a D.A right she promised the mom of a
man who got murdered that I'm gonna give
Justice for your son while doing
additional investigation she's built up
this extra huge case to say the reason
why he died is because this faction is
beefing with this faction you know what
she does to keep her promise let's lock
both of them up so really that's what it
is you know I mean everyone's like you
know social media is pretty dumb so
everyone's like yo they're only using
lyrics no there's murders right right
there's tons of murder there was a real
crimes going on there wouldn't be an
investment that's what social media says
you know I mean like social media will
have people think on a stupid level
well it's people like academics just on
streams saying some [ __ ] that got these
guys locked up no you're doing crimes
like yeah you know I mean like State's
not going to give you money to
investigate something unless there's a
legitimate concern but people online are
stupid and also rappers have a good way
of spinning it because they have the
influence they can go and they can speak
Kardashian tweeting about [ __ ]
releasing gonna how do you explain to
the people right how do you explain to
the people that
you have zero accountability with the
crime that's increasing right you just
make it up like oh no these guys are
targeting us because we come from a
certain community and we rap about
certain things but the things you rap
about are completely innocuous and we
have nothing to do within you know what
I mean it's tough but nobody talks about
the bodies you also have to I don't know
if you still have to I'm 38 but you had
to be real when I was growing up as a
rapper you can't just be talking that
[ __ ] and not live it yeah so if you're
talking it and then you're saying you're
real and then people are Prosecuting
you're like whoa whoa whoa y'all are
running with a narrative is BS it's like
that's what you're saying you say you
live your reps that's the whole point
why are you accusing me of being real
yeah yo the conversation nobody really
wants to really have is man as much as
we like these rappers and I would never
advocate for any of them even a little
baby like I love his music I want to
advocate for him because I don't know
what he's doing yeah yeah so I know
these guys as rappers I'm not in the
streets I don't know if these guys are
killers these guys are sending it I
don't know yeah they need to do the same
thing in California that's why we're
seeing rampant crime yeah you gotta
approach it like like I'm not saying
what she's doing is what needs to needs
to be done but if you don't approach
when crime starts to build where
everybody's like yo
what they're brazenly saying if somebody
walks into a restaurant like yo let's
Rob him broad daylight yeah that's crazy
if you're sometimes you got to start
indicting whole groups I'm sorry you
gotta you got you got to get aggressive
but you know California [ __ ] at least
the the DA's the police over there
Fulton County they're not that's Atlanta
yeah they're not yeah I mean eventually
it's gonna happen I think the people
start to get fed up enough where they're
like we need somebody to be responsible
or held accountable for what's happening
in the community and I don't know if
it's hit that in California I gotta like
we gotta like ask people over there I
think no there's not enough people
trying to recall gascon who came from
San Francisco ran that place to [ __ ]
came to La it's been run to [ __ ] it's
just gotten worse since covet and the
same thing it's like Atlanta probably
has what they have follow home robbery
someone tipping you off and those crimes
are just ramping in L.A would you I
asked you this before but like if you
went to LA are you moving different
knowing that no of course I'm not doing
none of that you're not even going out
there I'm no no no I'll go out there of
course I'll go anywhere well except
Chicago but
I wouldn't do many things that you know
you know one of these dumb terminology
that that you know when people try to
criticize me they'll throw out they'd be
like yo this [ __ ] never outside you
know what you know what that means I'll
give you the Negro translation for that
okay thank you outside and vulnerable
waiting for someone to take your life
property or for you're in a very
disadvantageous spot okay if they see
you outside with hella Security in a
secure location you know they say [ __ ]
aren't you available to kill yeah like
yeah I can't come slap you I can't come
take a chain I can't shoot you yeah so
you know um
when I go to La I take the you know I
used to stay in airbnbs that that was a
long time ago
um I used to even stay at certain hotels
where like you know sometimes maybe
people like other rappers but I realized
all my enemies are only in a only a rap
like I don't got an enemy in the world
who isn't a rapper yeah so that's on
YouTube you antagonizing that way but
what I'm saying and how I move
so all that means if I'm gonna go
somewhere just go to the place that a
rapper is gonna be